okay this is a video to explain how the
the magic orb booster works it's a it's
a magic orb half the time charge so if
when you click on this before you start
playing a level you're you're horrible
at your horrible charge up twice as fast
as it normally would so I was just going
to show you how that works in action to
go along with our guide on it 127 is one
of the most difficult levels it's right
up there with level 64 as far as how
thing you know how it's really hard to
get this thing charged up before you get
to pull your item is so I'm going to
play it once without it and I'm going to
try to do my best to complete the level
by making the biggest available matches
and see if see how close I get
so you can see you only have a few moves
you have every match counts because you
have to charge it up before you run out
you need to charge up with one left
because using the line blaster take some
moves up all that combines to make it
pretty difficult and you can see them
down to four moves right now I'm not
quite there yet so on this match I would
have to be the one where I've made it
all the way complete and I didn't get
there I don't think I made any major
mistake so I just sort of how the layout
was set up so now we'll play it again
with the left the booster and see what
happens all right so like I said you
just click on this ahead of time you'll
see a green tech there to show you that
it's activated so now well let's any
lies to do that over so now we'll do
that again and play the level and see
what happens
alright so you can see that we have this
this indicates that we're using that
booster at this time so I'm going to
play this exactly the same way as I did
last time making the biggest matches I
can find
and now I can complete the level with
seven moves left so you can see that to
really helpful booster for situations
like that and it's also one I you can
see I had seven of them there I'm
guessing that I got a lot of those from
the the bonus game because I've never
bought any boosters at all in this game
and I beat all the levels without them
so you can see like if you really get
frustrated here you might have one of
those that you got for free sitting
around and you'll be able to complete
the level so it's really useful tool
from levels like this one and I got a
really nice score there too because I
used it
and that's about all there is to it I
mean it there isn't much else to say you
have to do it on the level before you
start so make sure if you're having a
really hard time with one you go ahead
and I'm sure you all remember level 64
make sure you enable it ahead of time so
it's activated and then levels where you
need to charge the booster and a look at
a low amount of those would be a lot
easier let's see if we can get this one
taken care of too while we're at it just
to say get how fast it on actually
charged around yeah nothing like
finishing level 64 with 10 moves laptop
alright so if you have any questions
about this leave a comment below if you
want to know about the other boosters
will be writing guides and making videos
for all of them and make sure you like
this video if you found it helpful
thanks